this channel is code red for henry 6203  no response on a status check  this is a final call for troopa micah  may henry 6203  do you copy  attention citizens friends and family  trooper micah may nevada highway patrol  call sign henry 6203  lost his life while serving his  community with dignity  courage and valor we thank him for his  dedication  loyalty and service to the citizens of  the state of nevada  trooper may influenced many for his  unending compassion  respect for all people and service in  many facets of law enforcement  all those he served will remember him  trooper may please rest in peace knowing  that your legacy will live on through  your blood family  as well as your brothers and sisters in  blue your sacrifice will never be  forgotten  trooper micah may henry 6203  your end of watch 1042 time is july 29th  2021 at 10 43 hours  god speed sir rest in peace we have it  from here